similarities between Christianity and
Islam. One thinks that Jesus was a great
prophet, you know, the other thinks that
Jesus is God. One thinks, you know, the
Virgin Mary is the Virgin Mary. The
other one thinks, you know, Virgin Mary
was the Virgin Mary, right? So, I look
at these things and then I look at
Judaism and Judaism thinks that Jesus is
in hell burning and The Virgin
Mary is a And then Jews telling
you that Islam is the problem. I have a
huge problem with with several things in
the Quran.
>> You did not answer
it.
>> You know where else it's it's illegal to
have a church? Under Sharia law.
>> Listen to the liar. It's too easy. He
just
>> This is one video. If you care about the
more than skip it. By one donation,
you're going to help 1.8 million people
in need. 551,000 people who have been
fed through the emergency food aid. You
are going to be sponsoring 4,200
orphans. You will be helping 250,000
people in Gaza. You'll be helping
123,000 people to be fed through our
Kmani program. You will help feed
551,000
people through the emergency food aid.
56 massages that are going to be built
around the world and 74,000 given clean
safe water. That's why we want to keep
one um 100% donation policy. And in
order for us to keep 100, we need you to
help us by supporting this fund. So that
all of the stuff that I mentioned, you
get the reward for every single one of
them is far more important than the
dunya and you will see every penny that
you give on your makama. The decision is
yours. The link is there. Donate now.
Brothers and sisters and dear friends,
hope you guys are well in welcome to
another reaction video on my channel.
Alhamdulillah.
>> Alhamdulillah. Brothers and sisters,
hope you guys are going in. So, she told
me about Dan Bizerian Baerian where his
name is inshallah. So, may Allah guide
him to Islam inshallah. So, here's a
discussion with him with a Christian
Zionist.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> What oxymoron? What oxymoron? Christian
Judeo values. What values? If there's
any values that they share is the
Muslims with the Muslims,
>> you know, you know they say about your
God that he is a bastard
>> and he's burning in in his office.
burning in his hell
>> and they insult his mom
>> and he insults their mom
>> and they spit at the Christians
>> in in in Jerusalem. Yeah.
>> Yeah. And they and they and they and
they Subhan Allah they insult them. And
not only that, Muslims are Jews can pray
in a in a m in a mosque.
>> Yeah.
>> But not in a church.
>> Not in a church.
>> But they say the Judeo-Christian values.
>> You can't. Let's inshallah.
>> I'm unapologetically pro-Israel. My
support from Israel is Christianbased.
I'm pro-Israel because my Christian
beliefs and we'll just have to disagree
on this. When God told Abraham who after
his fight with Jesus became Israel, that
is the context of this conversation.
When when God tells him, I I will bless
those who bless you and curse those who
curse you and you know from you will
become uh a nation. He makes that
promise to Israel to be a nation. He
furthers on that that promise to to his
son.
>> He was blessing Abraham, not Israel. I
>> he
straight away he done him.
>> Yeah. And not only that,
>> he was he was he said he was blessing
Abraham. Yeah. And he was blessed
Abraham's first born who is Ishmael that
of him of him I will make a great nation
a great if you're talking about cuz
Kandis woman said this it's not talking
about that Israel today imagine imagine
you have Satanists and they say we're
going to call our country Israel
>> we going to say God blesses them it's
talking about them so it's it's just cuz
the title doesn't mean that well let's
carry on
>> also think that the Israel the Bible is
different than the Israel today and I
believe that covenant was broken when
they killed Christ and didn't accept
him.
>> And I'll say this with how horrible the
Jews have been historically. The Bible
even says this. The Bible says you will
become a stumbling block stumbling block
to to other nations. And even though
they they don't deserve it, the New
Testament did bring in a new covenant.
>> Doesn't Christianity say that you have
to accept Jesus in order to get into
heaven?
>> Correct.
>> Which they certainly do not cuz he's in
hell burning and I just don't
accept that.
>> Exactly. It's true. So he he just
basically pointed out that in the New
Testament he says you have to accept
Jesus.
>> Yes.
>> Does a Muslim accept Jesus?
>> Do we rever him and his mother?
>> Do we do we believe he's a messiah?
>> Yes.
>> In his second coming?
>> Does he done miracles?
>> Yes.
>> His miraculous birth?
>> Does do the Jews believe in any of them?
>> None of it.
>> Not only that, not only that, they
insult him.
>> Yeah.
>> This they insult him. They seek
neariness to God by insulting him.
>> Wow. Wow.
>> They're God's chosen people. I also
think that the Old Testament has been
trampled on a bit and there's a lot of
things that we haven't seen like the
Dead Sea Scrolls. There's other books
that were part of the, you know, Old
Testament that the Jews have just said,
you know, we don't want this in. I view
Judaism and Satanism is very similar to
me. The Old Testament just doesn't
resonate. I think,
>> wow, that's deep. He said that Satanism
and Judaism is the same thing. That's a
both statement. I wonder what he means
by that. Let's see. I hope you guys
enjoyed the video, guys. But before
that, please download the Salah Pro app,
brothers and sisters. We are a charity.
All of our services on the app is for
free. Free kibla finder, no ads, free
salah reminders, encourages to pray,
tells you salah times. You can book a
salah instructor, a Quran instructor.
You can order a guided prayer map for
absolutely free if you want to learn how
to pray salah. Videos on how to pray
salah, salah hubs, and many, many more,
brother sisters. We are not an app that
shares your information with third
parties. All of our services on the app
is for free. Download it now inshallah
and enjoy, guys. Let's go back to the
video. Jesus being God takes away from
what Jesus did because if you're a human
and you're walking a perfect path and
you're going through pain, I think it's
much more admirable and much more
impressive. The people that are pushing
the Quran are really adamant about that.
Cuz the people that have read the Quran
are sure that that's the right religion.
Christians are either right or wrong and
if they're right and if you don't accept
Jesus as your Lord and Savior, like
you're going to hell. That means that
3/4ers of the planet are going to hell
by default. I don't know. That premise
seems odd to me. A kid's born in Africa,
he's obviously at a big disadvantage if
he never sees a Bible or never hears the
word of God. Or a kid that's born into a
Muslim family that his parents tell him,
"Hey, the Quran is the way to go." Like,
I'm not going to have that kid burn in
hell. That
>> he's right. And in Islam, she chef, do
we believe in Christianity? They believe
that.
>> But for example, in Islam, do we believe
if a person who didn't read the Quran or
heard the message of Islam, what happens
to him?
>> If you have heard the message of Islam,
>> haven't.
>> You haven't. Oh, you are Allah on the
day of judgment. Allah is just and he's
going to put you through a test and if
you if you pass the test then you are
admitted to the people of
>> Dambarian thought that it applies to
Muslims and Christians not Christians
yet if you don't accept if someone
doesn't in the Amazon jungle hear about
Jesus but in Islam we believe God will
never punish a nation until he sends a
messenger and a child who didn't hear
the message of Islam will be
>> any elderly person young person it
doesn't matter it's irrelevant how old
you are
>> yes the If you have not, Allah says,
"We were not to punish until we sent a
messenger."
>> Exactly.
>> It's kind of where it doesn't seem to
fully align with me. What I'm saying is
the Old Testament doesn't align with
>> what I have experienced and learned
throughout my life as being correct. The
God of the Old Testament is like
vindictive.
>> So, you're right. that God and the way
he acted if you if you want to call it
that like any phase uh that that was an
appropriate time for then and this and
this is this is a new phase and there
being a whole another phase after this
uh for me there are some things that I
don't understand I don't I don't pretend
to know all the answers
>> you've got two billion people that are
going to tell you the Quran is correct
>> you're very harsh of Israel
>> yes
>> I feel like you give Islam a pass
>> and if you're going to be that critical
of this nation I I think there's a lot
of things you could be equally critical
to if you were consistent and held that
held that same standard to them.
>> Okay, one second. So, let's look at that
standard then. So, what's the standard?
Let's see what applies in the Old
Testament. Do we see any of that in the
Quran?
>> All right, let's be consistent.
>> Know a ton about Islam, but what I've
looked into
>> is the similarities between Christianity
and Islam. One thinks that Jesus was a
great prophet. You know, the other
thinks that Jesus is God. One thinks,
you know, the Virgin Mary is the Virgin
Mary. The other one thinks, you know,
Virgin Mary was the Virgin Mary, right?
So, I look at these things and then I
look at Judaism and Judaism thinks that
Jesus in hell burning and The
Virgin Mary is a I'm looking at
the similarities between Christianity
and and Islam and there's actually a
lot. They have Jesus in there. They have
similar stories of the Bible. There's
some different There you have it.
>> Yeah, it's funny. What does he say to
that? I wonder what his comeback is. I
would love to know cuz he's talking
about Judeo-Christian values. He's a
Christian Zionist. I want to know on
what basis do you support them? Is there
any similarity? Do they he just told him
the similarities? He's just thrown them
all at him. Let's see what he says
>> for sure. But I think when you're
talking about, you know, Jesus being
your Lord and Savior and being God and
you have another religion that thinks
that he's in hell burning and and
that he's a scumbag and his mother's a
To me, those two religions are at
odds before the one that thinks that
he's a great prophet, that he's going to
come back and save the world cuz that's
what Islam believes.
>> Thank you. Okay, let's see what I want
to know what he has to say with this
world. I'm so intrigued.
>> Jesus is going to come back and save the
world. So, I'm looking at these two
religions as kind of like brother and
sister religions. Granted, they have
their their differences, no doubt, but
the fundamentals seem more aligned. And
then I look at Judaism and it's like
Jesus is such a pillar of Christianity
that I think you have to start at how
they view your Lord and Savior. And so
that's where I have a hard time with
this whole Judeo-Christian values with
Judaism and Christianity being handinand
and then Jews telling you that Islam is
the problem. That's kind of the angle
that I'm coming at it from is, you know,
is is the similarities in religious
belief, how they, you know, view Jesus.
I have a huge problem with with several
things uh in the Quran that are that are
just drastically drastically
>> different. He did not answer.
>> He totally ignored it.
>> Yes.
>> That's unbelievable. He totally ignored
because look to you Jesus is the main
figure.
>> Yes.
>> And and this is what you deem to be God.
Not even a prophet. You see to be God.
It's not even a prophet.
>> He just told him exactly the where we
agree with the Christians.
>> Where do we depart with the with the
Jews? Yes.
>> And he forgot all of that and he's going
to go to a run the uh
>> so you can see that intellectual
cowardice. This is what it is. But let's
see what he had to say. What's the issue
with the Quran
>> different from the Christian uh religion
when they teach that in the Quran not
just the the the hadith they are called
to subjugate non-believers. That's
absolutely nothing like Christianity.
>> They say in Judaism though that you
>> I dare him
>> Yeah. to bring in the Quran where it
says subjugate non-believers. Yeah.
>> Okay. Good.
>> Yeah. Where does it say it?
>> The only one is
when it says when they paying Jiza.
>> Okay. Hang on. Hang on.
>> This Jiza that we speaking about and
we're making a whole fuss about it.
>> You know, by two days, by two days is
$30.
>> Yeah.
>> A year. And that a year. And not only
that, a child doesn't pay it.
>> A widow doesn't pay it. An elderly
person doesn't pay it. A disabled
doesn't pay it. A woman doesn't pay it.
And the only people that can pay it
people who are
>> fighting age
>> at fighting age
>> and also
>> and they are and they'll not join the
army and they are protected and if the
Muslims cannot protect them they have to
give them the
>> this happened this happened in one of
the the Khalif's time and not only that
they can also serve in military and not
pay Jiza.
They can say, "Okay, we're going to
serve in the minion, not pages." So,
let's see. Let's see.
>> Kill all basically all all Gentiles
should die.
>> There's a reason that uh that's that's
not my faith. Thankfully, I don't have
to defend that. But but that's actually
a little bit my point. You're really
upset about that with with Judaism.
There's a lot
>> the best of the Gentiles.
>> There's there's a lot of similarities in
the Quran. You're just not as as uh
again as as hard on again as as hard on
them.
>> And he said that I don't need to defend
that. Of course, you need to defend
that. You know why? Cuz the God Jesus is
the God of the Old Testament. So you do
have to defend it. So don't come and see
that's their faith. Jesus is the God of
the Old Testament. Let's see what is in
the Quran that's similar to the Old
Testament. Let's see
>> as as you are with Israel.
>> I just haven't seen the gnarly stuff in
the Quran like I've seen in the Talmud.
Like the Quran doesn't say it's okay to
lie, cheat, and steal and rape non-Jews.
I mean, that's a pretty big one, right?
Like if you can lie, cheat, and steal
from people that aren't Jews. And I also
see like Jews as being very tribal. And
I look at the percentage of problems
they're they're responsible for and the
percentage of the population they have.
And it's so disproportionate. I also
don't really have to deal with Islam.
Islam is less than 1% of America. So
this, you know, when all these Jews are
telling me that like Islam has taken
over America, I don't see that as being
a real thing. But I do see 36 Jews in
Congress and I see four Muslims. Right.
So I look at these disparities and I
look at the influence that Israel has on
our country and the influence that Islam
has and it's just it's not even
comparable.
>> Exactly. That's a good point. And not
only that, for example, these Zionists,
they they it's like an investment. They
invest 100 million pounds and get
billions of pounds back to Israel and
their only thing is Israel first.
>> So much so, like you know, if you look
at there's so many
takuentes
and and that
>> they they all they saying what is
America first?
>> Yeah, exactly. They're not they're not
it's Israel first. Your country is so
can you imagine your country is run and
told what to do by another foreign
government.
>> Also, you know, Muslims for the most
part have been like very gracious of me.
You know, Jews have me over. They tried
to extort me. They've done all this.
>> My allegiance to Israel really has more
to do with the interpretation.
>> Do you not agree with that? Cuz he is
generalizing Jews a lot. He's
generalizing like that's not right cuz
that's not fair to put every Jew person
in that category that every Jew you
might have bad experience. There might
be a bad experience with Muslims or
Christians. You can't come and
generalize every single Jew. I I
disagree with that.
>> He's he's he's not generalizing in that
way what he's he's he's quoting the
Talmud and what happens in the Talmud.
>> Yeah. But that's not you know like Islam
like in Islam Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
were they believing Jews at the time of
Muhammad. Yeah. They were Abdullah.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. But but but he's also making a
private like I dealt and they tried to
rob me. A Muslim could do that. I don't
think that's fair
>> of the Bible and the Old Testament and
for them to say, you know, bless those
who bless you and curse you those who
curse you. I don't think it's a
coincidence that America has been so
blessed and why are they blessed? Who is
Israel's biggest ally?
>> One second. Hold on a second. Let's
talk. This is They are blessed. What are
you blessed with that you have uh
adultery for example? uh the amount of
suicide out of
>> understand what he says
>> they are blessed by having Israel as
their that's what that's my point though
the thing is if America is blessed
because of their relation with Israel
>> okay I'm asking how are they blessed are
they blessed with suicide rates murder
rates pornography incest pedophilia
immorality addiction gambling addiction
the heroin addiction the crystal meth
there's this new drug there that's
turned everyone zombies what blessings
are you talking about not only does a
country take money from you while you've
got homeless, millions of homeless,
millions of drug addicts, millions of
alcohol, alcoholics, uh millions of
people. Do you know 50% they say 50% of
uh soon 50% of every household is going
to be a single mother broken down of
homes. Yes. Uh all these Can you tell me
what do you measure blessing with? So
what's blessing is Israel given to you
except robbing your money, telling you
what to do. Yes. Um having sending your
officials in the Congress, whatever it
is, to an island. So they can blackmail
them, record them and use it against
them if they don't.
>> That's coming out soon. Coming out soon.
>> Is that how they bless? How is Israel
blessing you? It looks like Israel is
cursing you with all due respect.
>> We are. I
>> But have we been blessed though? Because
since Israel,
>> we're the greatest country in the world.
>> Well, but when we were in the 40s, we we
could be better. We could be better.
>> But since our support of Israel, we've
had this emergence of transgenderism, of
homosexuality, the attack on
masculinity. We've had, you know, this
this feminism being pushed. a Jewish
private bank that they called the
Federal Reserve. They get to print our
dollars and just decide what interest
rate that we pay them.
>> Like what the is that? Is America better
today than it was in the '
>> 40s? That's morally, you know, morally
better
>> morally. No.
>> And we've been blessing Israel since the
40s. So I'm just saying
>> so if it's morally no in the Bible it
says you shall know them by their
fruits.
>> So if that's the case, look at the
fruits that Muslims produce. Yes. By
saying what? No to adultery. No to
pornography. No imam, no no imam can own
a pornography site. Go and look at
rabbis. There's rabbis that own pornhub.
Yes. Um these these disgusting
degenerate only fans.
>> Yes. Yes. Yes. All of them own it.
Flipping unholy shami dirt bag. Yeah. So
if you look at it, if you look at the
fruits of Muslims, yes. No sex outside
of marriage. Yes. No gambling, no
addiction, no sexual objectifying women.
Yes. No degeneracy, no LGBTQ, no. So if
you look at it, fine. It doesn't make
sense
>> for sure. Or actually maybe the fifth, I
guess, you know, 48, whatever. So let's
just say 1950, you know, I think since
1950, America's had a moral decline. So
I don't I mean, have we been blessed
since we've been blessing Israel?
>> For whatever reason, you you credit that
that moral slide to uh to Jews.
>> You can't attribute it to Islam. They're
not running our country. They're not
running the media. They're not running
Hollywood. They're not pushing this
stuff, you know.
>> Uh correct. But
>> what the hell, bro? What the hell? Zist.
Exactly. This guy's an idiot. He owned
it.
>> What an idiot.
>> He owned it.
>> She had destroyed him. intellectually
got finished.
>> They just Hollywood just Hollywood on
itself.
>> I it it's pretty clear to me that it's
it's liberals. That that is a liberal
agenda.
>> Who gives the liberals their talking
points? The Jewish media is giving the
liberals their talking points. if we're
talking about true liberalism
uh and and at their core really anti-
good and and anti-Christianity
uh and and and anti- relligion which
would be an odd ally for for someone to
give them orders and talking points that
is completely religious and completely
>> focused. Well, that's what the Jews did
when they took over Russia, right? The
Bolsheviks. They made it illegal to be
Christian. They burned down 40,000
Christian churches. They killed tens of
millions of Christians. They made it
illegal to criticize Jews. They made
religion illegal. So that's exactly what
the communism did. Communists did. And
that was from Karl Marx. That was from a
Jew. Communism, Marxism, that's all
Jewish creation. So you know where else
it's it's illegal to have a church under
Sharia law.
>> Listen to the liar. Listen to the liar.
>> He just dropped all these facts. I
didn't even know about that. What's it
called? B what?
>> The Bwick revolution in in Russia.
>> That's when millions were killed. And
who were the leaders of it? They were
Jews.
>> Subhan Allah. That is crazy.
>> Bosik and Bikin.
>> Let's see what he has to say for that.
>> Under Sharia law.
>> Stop. Stop. Stop.
>> He throw all of that at him.
>> Yeah.
>> And the man instead of defending from
>> Can you have churches under
>> Sharia?
Or else it's is illegal to have a
church.
>> It's illegal to have a church under
Shar.
>> No, it's not actually. You are allowed
to have churches. And not only that,
>> he is a
>> He's an intellectual He is an
absolute. It isn't sexually bankrupt.
Not only that, in Islam there was
Christians and they had their churches.
Not only that, there were treaties made.
>> The holy the holy super in Jerusalem. In
Jerusalem, the keys are by Muslims. The
Muslims have the keys. And not only
that, your most holiest sites, Muslims
open the doors for you. Yes. Not only
that, the prom when he talk about
Jerusalem, he said, "I would have let
the Muslims play in the church, but I
afraid that they would."
>> He was asked to pray in the church. He
said if I do pray in that church
tomorrow someone will come and make
claim of it.
>> Exactly. To protect and there was
treaties made where your churches are
protected, your place of worship, your
your crosses were protected. Subhan
Allah. So imagine that
>> Egypt Egypt Coptic Christians
>> Egypt Coptic Christians until today they
had they have their their oldest
churches their oldest churches since
that time in Jerusalem in Syria in
Jordan. So, how come?
>> Um, true. They have they've got
Christian churches and
>> true Sharia law does not true Sharia law
does not Israel bombed them all.
>> Does does not does not allow
>> for for other religions.
>> A lie.
>> This is a lie. This Darian didn't
obviously know this.
>> No, he said to him, he know he just said
to him they have it's not a proper
Sharia law.
>> No, he did. He did. But I don't think
that knows you are allowed to have the
church in synagogues and other
synagogues.
>> Yeah.
>> Y
>> I mean well they they say there's
there's three religions of the book
according to Islam and Christianity um
Judaism and and and and Islam
>> which you would say in anywhere Jews
have been is has has not has not been
has not been beneficial
as just a general statement.
>> Morally definitely not.
>> Okay. Show me another place where
Muslims continue to go into get better.
>> When you take
>> What are you talking about? I've read
Islam ruled the world. Wherever they
went, they enriched it. Do you see when
Islam ruled the world? Yes. Half of the
planet Earth. Okay. Do you see us
stealing the crown jewels and bringing
it back to Mecca?
>> Do you see the gold the stuff in Mecca?
No, you don't.
>> Not only Not only that,
>> the Jews have always flourished in
Islam.
>> Yes. Exactly. in in in
>> they had they were wirs
and that what happened when when the the
Muslims went were kicked out in 1400 and
something
>> what happened Ali
>> they the Catholics started killing them
>> started killing them
the the Spanish Inquisition they had to
force them And not only that when the
Jews were running away from Nazi Germany
the in France the Muslims gave them fake
identities open the doors and open the
doors to them. But but only not only
that you know in north North Africa,
Morocco, Tunisia and Algeria, all the
Muslims, all the the the Jews that fled
the Spanish Inquisition, they went to
North Africa. and Sulman Alani. Yeah.
You your ancestors Sullean Alani,
>> he
>> took them to Istanbul.
>> Wow.
>> He used to send he used to send ships to
take them back to Istanbul.
>> Wow. Exactly. Exactly. during the
Ottoman Empire. You got sisters.
>> Even one, even one rabbi said, "If the
Muslims were ruling the world in World
War II, we would have had six million
extra Jews alive today."
>> Aged men from war turned countries and
you bring them into a country they have
no allegiance to, you're going to have
problems, right? Like, and I don't think
that it matters if they're Muslim or
Christian. Africa is mostly Christian.
It's not a Muslim problem. You know,
guys coming over the border with
fentanyl coming from Mexico, they're not
Muslim, right? So, I don't think that's
a Muslim problem. I think that's a
border problem. And you look at who's
funding the NOS's and who's pushing
these open border policies and this
melting pot idea and it's all Jews. Our
government has to be America first. It
can't be Jew first and Israel second and
America third. Anything else is treason.
There's a lot of Jewish congressmen that
have more allegiance to Israel than
America. And they have dual citizenship
with a foreign country. That is literal
treason. I mean Malcolm X talked about
this. Responsibility has to come with
these positions of power. Like it just
has to, you know, like if it was Muslims
doing this, if it was Chinese doing
this, like everybody would be going
crazy about it. What is going on
with our country? We've never been more
divided. We've never been more racist.
Like I feel like we're being destroyed
from within. It's because of this Jewish
supremacy problem that we have. Because
if you're a small minority and you're
controlling a large group of people,
what do you want? Divide and conquer.
The more the whites are like, "Oh, we
got a black problem." And the
Christians like, "We got a
Muslim problem." and everybody's
pointing their finger and nobody's
realizing who's actually causing these
problems.
>> It's
>> okay. I would I would disagree with him
on certain points because the thing is
he's um he's he's and this this is this
is um I believe this is anti-semitic a
bit because he's he's trying to make it
seem as if every Jew is behind it and
that's not right because we get the same
thing as every Muslim is like that. So
we have to be fair and say here I'm so
sorry like here it's becoming
anti-semitic because now you are making
it seem like every Jew is I've got I
know Rabbi Beck from Stanford
>> yes he's the one who comes to all the
Palestinian marches I know many Jewish
people etc. Okay. So the thing is to put
them into that category is wrong.
There's Jews who are against Israel and
what they're doing. Okay. So I think
here he's going a little bit extreme. I
understand his points. He's got very
valid points etc. But we have to be
careful because you can't vify every
single Jew.
>> You know what's happening?
>> This America first movement. Yeah.
>> They Trump came and he came on a winning
papers that I'm I'm putting America
first. Exactly. Then they saw then they
saw that 33 billion went to Israel
>> and they saw other things and they saw
what happened in Palestine and that they
said well hang on these this is our tax
dollars.
>> Yeah.
>> So
>> exactly
>> and then you know we have a a saying in
Arabic. It says if one fish stinks it
makes the whole
basket smell. Yeah.
>> If a fish goes off and you know when
fish goes off it, it makes a smell.
>> So if if you put a fish smelly fish
amongst fresh fish, they're all going to
smell.
>> So when you put someone a bad a bad
apple somewhere, it gives you bad
apples.
>> I mean guys, that's it in for me. That
was interesting. He absolutely
obliterated and the guy couldn't answer
nothing. He couldn't even
>> when he when he cornered him, he went
straight away. What about Sharia?
>> Unbelievable. Answer answer what he's
been telling you.
>> Exactly. Exactly guys. I'm going to say
inshallah that's it from me and
bless you brother sisters in do not
forget we've got the dros podcast being
launched next Wednesday a brand new
show. Alhamdulillah where we'll have
different guests from all around the
world. Different dua we're going to join
us every Wednesday. We're going to be
live from 6:00 to about 10. We're going
to talking about dahad and the enemies
of Islam attacking Islam. And we are
going to be defending inshallah and
making Allah's till next time.